can you introduce yourself to the
audience of the nexus institutes and you
wrote this great book the first of a
series of four on the phone optical but
what are you I journalist a writer
political man well I think the best way
to describe myself is the experience
that I brought to bear in writing this
book mm-hmm I grew up in Chicago
Illinois Illinois is Lincoln state it's
in the middle of the United States and I
have that perspective that I can that
vantage point that I can bring to
American society culture and politics I
became a journalist and had been a
journalist for many years I worked for
such publications as the New Republic
the Washington Post and The New Yorker
written many books about American
politics and I served with President
Clinton in the White House I've been
active in campaigns and elections as a
Democrat and I'm a historian why is he
good to go so much simple with American
politics I at the age of 12 became
entranced with a presidential political
campaign and that campaign was in
nineteen sixty and the candidate was
John F Kennedy when I grew up in Chicago
there was a political organization it
was a democratic party organization and
every part of the city had what was
called a precinct captain who was a
member of the Democratic Party and that
precinct captain recruited me as a boy I
was
just a boy to help him after school to
get people to vote and I would go around
and speak to my neighbors and say on
Election Day and say you would vote and
the reward was that my precinct captain
took me to the rally to see John F
Kennedy and then made an enormous
impression on me shortly after that I
was taken to Springfield Illinois which
is where Lincoln was from and
Springfield has many of the sites that
Lincoln was involved in the state
capitol his law office the small little
town where he had lived outside of
springfield as a young man and shortly
after that martin luther king came to my
city and I saw dr. King and so I saw
even in in the North not in the south of
the civil rights movement and its
greatest leader and all of these things
combined to impress upon me and awakened
in me an interest in American politics